[Music]
okay well my name is David Malone I'm a
documentary filmmaker and a writer what
I've just finished doing was working for
Universal Pictures making a cinema
release documentary on artificial
intelligence I'm really pleased for it's
it gonna be a good film that's called
them I think it's gonna be called we
have to talk about AI and I think it's
gonna be great
and why do we have to talk about AI well
several reasons the one is because if
you don't the conversation is going to
be had by a lot of techy boys who are
billionaires who are going to decide
what the future is because they know
better than you and having interviewed
them they really think this so it's a
kind of conversation where you need to
get involved now because otherwise
they'll have built it and they'll be too
late they'd like to talk about AI for
everyone but when they say things like
well hey I will do things for you will
it will but mostly to do things to you
and we all need to see that facial
recognition is coming and there's a
company I can't tell you its name
because I get in trouble tatting for
work in the UK and what they say is our
AI can identify you know in a huge crowd
it can pick out any individual and read
that person's emotional state you think
okay they're strapline is we will be
able to tell if someone is in an
emotionally heightened potentially
dangerous emotional state and get
security to intervene before they do
something how do you feel about that
that's slightly dodgy isn't it slightly
yeah slightly but in what way can people
respond to that well you could say to
your politicians wake the hell up
because at the moment the politicians
are doing nothing I mean there are a
couple of sort of ineffectual not quite
Buffon's but just intellect they're just
people who vote and there's me Martha
sight so it's very clever chaps came
around and told me it's gonna be
marvellous and you'd be great you'll be
beneficial for everyone and they're the
gatekeepers they're the people are
looking after things for you so if you
leave it to them you're sunk but you
still believe that politics sort of has
control of tech families I don't think
it does at the moment no I agree with
you it doesn't but it will need to and
the other reason I've been apart from
that practical reason is because what AI
will be able to do poses really deep
philosophical questions for us when the
one that I asked lots of them about is
what is it you want from AI I mean what
do you want when you think AI and when
you ask people enough what they want is
something that will do all of the stuff
for the middle make the bed they'll make
a cake it'll figure out how to get the
cheapest flight and we're talking about
AI which even if it isn't conscious will
be like being conscious you know those
have got those little Google boxes you
can speak to and in the end you end up
with something that's almost the slave
it will do everything you want to do it
can't say no you can be as rude to it as
you like and you think yeah but it's
it's a it's a machine it's it's it's not
it's not you're not really enslaving it
it's a machine but how would you feel
about your child growing up interacting
with the Machine like that
it's my worries not that
we harm the machines I wonder what it
does to us our moral fiber if if you
live in a world where you have a machine
that's sort of like cumin and you treat
it like a slave you get the sense though
that it was a thought out sort of value
LED or you know philosophical viewpoint
they had or it was just sort of
technology for technology's sake they
were interested in the progress of the
technology rather than sort of how it
drives forward with it yeah that I mean
that's one of the questions isn't it and
the answer was some of them will talk to
you about I'll give you some examples I
can't quote them word for word or I love
the fringe their copyright so these are
paraphrases and I can't tell you who
either
otherwise I'm lawyer will come dragging
out by the neck but I I asked what a
couple of my simple these these machines
will have to make moral choices if you
have a if you have a an autonomous
killing machine and we have them it's
gonna make ethical choices about is it
right you know if there's a a terrorist
that it wants to kill but there are 25
children sitting around do you kill the
terrorists and blow up all the children
or don't you and humans will be out of
that loop we're in the loop at the
moment and there's a little switch
literally a switch you can keep humans
in the loop when it comes to my shooting
match that switch gets switched off
because the whole value of AI machines
is that they react faster than humans so
if you keep a human in the loop
it's as slow as humans and you may as
well not have the AI so there will be
really serious ethical issues or even
driving cars you know do you program the
car so that if a group of children run
out into the road do you mow down the
children and some and you survive or
does the car swerve off the road and him
in bed you and your brains and a brick
wall and I said well who and they said
oh don't worry we're gonna put we're
gonna program in values I said well
whose values and the answer was nice
ones okay it's a deep philosophical
position nice ones
and you know I think different cultures
will program in different values but
who's deciding do you have your own
ideas of why this urged self outsource
whether it's morality or you know robots
to bring up your kids why is that become
a progression in which we're seeing yeah
well a lot of people some of the
scientists I can think of one in
particular and their answer is what
humans are so rubbish at this we are
irrational and we have prejudices and
we'll make na eyes won't have these
things it said they will because we they
feed off big datasets of our behavior so
there will be some kind of prejudice in
there but you won't even be able to
argue with it I mean that there's an AI
that's used in America right now I think
13 states use it and it's in it they
decided that they would have an AI
because it would much more even-handed
to decide which criminals should get
parole because humans are so biased and
so this thing was making the decisions
this person yes that won't gets parole
this person no goes back to the clink
and an NGO began to look at this and
they actually went to court and they got
to look at the raw data and it turns out
black American for 13 times more likely
to be denied parole by the AI than the
white person had exactly the same crimes
so but there's this notion that it'll be
better cuz it's a machine it'll be
fairer well it won't be it'd be worse
because if you made a decision I didn't
like as a judge I could I could come and
pick at your chambers and I could say I
want to know why you said that you can't
do that with an AI because the code is
proprietorial it's their private
property you're not allowed to know and
that's another thing that came out on
the this particular case I'm talking
about even though they won the case to
show that was unfair
the company said yeah but you can't find
out why because that's our private
property so there's a lot of questions
which we need to work through now and we
need to be the ones asking because their
money involved is Japan's every company
in every country knows the people who
get to the market first will own the
rest of the world and Putin said it and
he was right and he was said up some
panel and said whichever country cracks
general AI will rule the world and he
wasn't exaggerating everybody knows it
there are examples of ways in which AI
is helping us understand where it is to
be human
any positive stories coming out of
there's lots of positive stories and it
is it is another way of saying what is
consciousness and what's the
relationship between consciousness and
self-awareness and and it's making us
understand that those two things and and
the difference between being clever and
being conscious they're not they're not
the same thing I mean most AIS will be
zombies like in the zombie films they're
really quick but there's no nobody home
so it's doing all those sort of things
there's tremendous good but I think
we'll only realize the good if if the
conversation has had more wisely
otherwise it won't do things for you
it'll do things to you for someone
else's profit they sort of mystery is it
I mean you know and it is a
transformative technology and people
need to get involved that was what was
fun about doing that project course and
your work is focused on documentary
often tackling a lot of the why
questions yes questions which are
offerings of dealt with in universities
or institutions but you've chosen to do
so through documentary community
well it was a very poor decision from
the point of view of becoming wealthy
and well-known because the broadcaster's
have essentially abdicated that and it's
it sad when I started the BBC of a long
time ago yeah there are about eight or
nine strands of documentaries which none
of you love you won't have heard of
anything because of
being canceled I could I could name four
or five and the broadcaster's aren't
there they were denied there's been no
dumbing down and we love these deep
questions bollocks
they don't what they wanted spectacle in
titillation and that for history you
know with the little bear cubs survive
let's watch this is great stuff but
ideas they're not so keen on but you can
still get them made and I like I like
ideas asking why and and although the
scientists they always say well we don't
deal with why we do with the how and the
what actually when they're off the clock
they love talking about why and you
you've done documentary about why why we
are here or why are we here yeah yeah
here are the answers to those questions
who did you go about talking to to find
out well nobody has the answers and
that's what makes it fun but what I tend
to do is just to try and pick a question
which i think is really an interesting
one and then show that people come to it
with very different very different
notions very different set of
assumptions and it's really that it's
it's stepping back from the question and
getting people to show you what their
assumptions are I'm not so much
interested in their answers it's it's
when you get to see wall what are the
assumptions behind what this person says
and that's what it's really interesting
I think and that one was just that
series was was great it was it just said
can you believe in meaning in the
universe if you don't believe in God
they broke down to two camps those who
said there is wake up and smell the
barbed wire there's no meaning the sort
of arch materialist reductionist and
then there were the religious people who
said there is meaning because God makes
their meaning and I'm not I don't
believe in God so I wanted to be in the
middle and what I found something up on
hey the religious people
and the fun and the reductionist
although there are you know they
disagree they both turned on me and said
well you can't have that but I think you
can and I think there are if there's a
coming revolution in science which is
the project I want to do next
which I think we're on the cusp and they
make huge revolution I think dualism
going back to Descartes you know which
he ruled out I think it is coming back
and scientists even the physicists here
know I was speaking to several of them
in the last few months they're not
willing to sit in public yet but it is
happening dualism is back what's led to
that radical change of reimbursing the
jewel ism two things I think one is the
role of information and this is this is
what I'm writing about now is a project
called RGB and it's it's that there's
this notion and it's a it's an idea it's
not that it's my conclusion it's that we
used to think the universe was
essentially made of two things matter
and energy and I and information or
ideas was just a human invention people
are now beginning to wonder if
information itself is as fundamental of
thing as matter and energy which doesn't
sound right when you first say it but
think about this there is information in
the code of DNA as they're not what was
there before you came along but is that
not comes to this to be part of matter
no it's instantiated
in matter because I can take that code
and I can write it down a bit of paper
or I can enter it into computer and the
information is the same whether it's in
the DNA or on a bit of paper or in a
computer code because I can program
machine with my program to build DNA so
the information was obviously in the
machine wasn't it because it was telling
it what to do and then a copy of that
information in a different physical form
is in the DNA so the information was
just in different forms but the
information was the information wasn't
it it was in the DNA I wrote it down a
bit of paper and then I probed it into a
machine which could build DNA which had
the information in it so this is what
they begin to think and it changes the
story of life completely it doesn't it
doesn't say all of our science is wrong
at all
but it does suggest that what suggests
lots of things but for one thing it says
that all causality doesn't flow from the
atoms upwards that ideas
push push the electrons around that
rules out since they cut its back is it
bad is it it's like a new form though of
like that dualism or is it back it's a
new form of jewelries I mean it's not
it's not it's not
there's the material world and then this
girl not at all but that you will get
cited and we all talked to Roger
tomorrow Roger Penrose and others who
say very seriously that there's a
non-physical dimension there is that
dimension this dimension that dimension
and then there's a non-physical
dimension a proper dimension in which
ideas exist now I'm not sure I can go
that far but fit proper physicists
mathematicians biologists are saying
this so it makes it terribly exciting
because you couldn't have that
conversation ever since they car so
you're talking about a revolution of at
least 400 years are you and what would
they look at as the origins of this that
asked them they don't know yet that
they're staying up pretty late thinking
about it and it's great fun and what I'm
what I want to do I'm trying to write a
book and make up tried to get a series
funded retelling the story of life and
that's what the project RGB is RGB just
sends for red blue and green because you
can tell the story of life in this story
of a dance between matter energy and
information in three chapters because
for that to work you have to power it I
mean matter gives a body it gives form
to information like you said you the
information is got to be somewhere isn't
it the information decides what what
that form will be and then Energy's got
a power they don't get nothing you have
something for nothing in the universe
and so the structure of the story I'm
trying to tell is that there have
essentially been three chemicals which
have powered that dance of matter
information energy
water blue world chlorophyll the green
world and hemoglobin the red world so
you can tell this tell the story in
three acts and that's from that's
project I'm doing nouns so say we
accepted that information was a separate
entity
what now can that radically change well
yes I mean one of the things I think it
really does change is what kind of
creatures are we and it's been for a
very long time we've been seen as the
robots that walk around so that our
genes can express ourselves
and there is no such thing as free will
and consciousness is about as useful as
the froth on the top of your beer it's
it's a net phenomena it doesn't mean
anything and the self doesn't exist you
think it does but that's the last bit
doesn't that's the standard story this
would change all of that and say that
all still exists all of that matter and
all of the causality that flows from
atoms upwards still there but there is
now causality that comes down from the
top from ideas and when you get a form
that in sniffs physical form to ideas or
information that physical form because
it instantiates the ideas those ideas
now have an impact so it changes our
view of ourselves quite radically and it
brings freewill back or at least it
opens the door wide open to free will I
think it it does give a very different
notion of what the condition of being
alive is and I mean people are now
talking about pan psychism
you know that consciousness isn't
something produced by the brain but it's
a property of matter perhaps right I'm
not sure I believe that but people are
really talking about this stuff now and
I find that quite that's a great time to
be alive I mean you know instead of
being all these questions you can't talk
about yeah you can it's great but what
what is what is that shift that's like
made people talk about it again
I think it's that I think the
shortcomings of the standard story you
get to all these things which are your
the phenomena of your life like you say
I am conscious and I'm me I'm aware of
my consciousness there's a me inside
here and the standard story keeps saying
I know those don't exist let's focus on
ecology you think it does but it doesn't
you think you're there but you're not
you think you're conscious but it's just
a trick of your genes and you and I
think people lost faith and science is
I'm not saying it's religion but faith
is a very important thing for scientists
because they have to have the faith that
they're not wasting their entire life on
a theory which is going nowhere
most scientists if you get to it they
don't like the word faith but they have
to have faith that that it's a good
thing to commit their lives to and not
that and people have lost faith in the
story which keeps saying consciousness
doesn't exist self-awareness the self
doesn't exist I think they've just sort
of said I'm not sure about that and and
also the whole business of causality
running from the bottom are just is
beginning to look weak enough that you
should be other question it's no a lot
of people are saying it's not good
enough just for you to say oh no you can
talk about them and that's great it's
it's great that you can now talk about
those things and I think it does I don't
know what the answer will be it might
turn out that it's all wrong I doubt it
I think at least some of it will be
right but it changes massively the way
we think the universe works where to go
from here how do you research um not me
yeah well I mean I you seem quite a
skeptical still have like pan psychism
or the idea that's like well what am I
gonna be very very close friends is
writing an enormous token upon pan
psychism and in McGilchrist who I think
is a brilliant man and his last book the
master Ian's emissary I think when
history comes to look at it they'll go
Freud Jung
skip everyone else McGilchrist maybe of
people don't think that's true but I
think it is I think it's the most
significant book written on
consciousness for a very long time and
he he wants to put this view of pan
psychism and everyone sniggers at pan
psychism and I find it difficult but
when you actually look at it your
choices are consciousness which is
unlike any other part of the physical
universe
is magic somehow produced by matter and
there's just a somehow it's just a you
know sense and then you get to add
somehow and then we skip over to
consciousness on the other side of the
somehow we have no idea how how is it
that some form of matter which in all
other forms like that or this isn't
thinking but then I arrange it in some
way and it's good doesn't just process
the information somebody's home I'm
conscious and that is there's no zero
explanation for that which is why the
standard story says no you're not
conscious there is information being
processed and it fools you into thinking
you're conscious and Pan psychism says
maybe your way around that is to say
that the universe really isn't the way
we thought it was and that matter isn't
some things are just part of matter like
mass it's not that you have to get a
certain amount of matter together and
then mass comes into existence it
disease right from the very start isn't
it it's the fabric of the unit there so
why couldn't consciousness be like that
and then what we're arguing about is
certain kinds of consciousness express
themselves in a way that we can interact
with we can interact with it whereas the
consciousness in that hill over there
it's conscious in some sense but it's
not it's not wired up in it in the way
that I can ever interact with it I find
that it's like dropping a depth charge
to water my brain goes but once I got
past that what are my grounds for saying
that's rubbish
I don't think I have any grounds I find
it difficult but that's not good enough
to just sort of turn your back on it and
walk away and that's what it's so
interesting at the moment he's from
Descartes onwards everyone said look
we're not most things in a cupboard and
everyone should just walk away
and everyone's some people now yeah
really notable people have gone back
open the cupboard said let's have a look
at these things again it's great and you
thought as an opening more in science
which has traditionally be seen as like
looking for objective knowledge or
objective truth the problem with that
question it's a good question I mean I
think it's a great question but the
problem is um the the way that those two
words objective and subjective what they
mean comes from the old paradigm so it's
very difficult to not import the old
assumptions with those words isn't it
because it sort of says objective
knowledge is truth that's always true
and subjective is just you made it up
and ever since quantum mechanics it's
the dirty secret of quantum because
these objective subjective just doesn't
seem to be like that objective is
Springs from the stuff of the universe
and subjective is something that comes
out of the human mind and those we're
going to end up with those two
definitions changing because if somehow
the stuff that subjectivity is made from
either consciousness or information is
part of the physical universe and that
you can't sort of say this the physical
universe over here and that's subjective
and then we've got this frothy rubbish
you stuff over here they get collapse
together and we don't have a word for it
that's I think that's what is so
interesting is we referred 400 years
using those words to explore what those
assumptions that those words come from
entail and we've come to a point where
those assumptions now have undermined
themselves and you could end up with
people really really need
definitions of some of our deepest
assumptions I think you hit the jackpot
I think you're alive at a great time is
it is it possible do you think humans
will come to that plane well we we
understand these questions I think we'll
come to a point where we understand them
very differently from the way we do now
you know I love reading history and if
you go back and read the stuff from the
late medieval period you realize that
you're reading the words but you realize
that what those words meant to the
people then is not at all
what it means to you because you're on
the other side of a transition and
that's what's going to happen to us I
think and to be alive well the
transitions happening crikey
you won the jackpot and just a few more
quick questions for social media
I wondered if there's any musicians
filmmakers authors who have inspired you
in your work that you would like other
people to read listen to real doesn't
have to be alive or they can be dead or
alive I think people should read when
Schrodinger's what is life and what is
consciousness
two short things and absolutely
brilliant you should definitely read him
McGill Chris it's a bit of a tome but
it's brilliant absolutely brilliant even
if it's wrong it's so fertile the
hundred questions pop into a head from
reading it which gives you them to think
about filmmakers but to filmmakers I
suppose who've influenced me the most
would be my dad whose shadow I have
always lived in he was a really great
filmmaker he he did cosmos with Carl
Sagan and he did sent a man with Jacob
Bronowski and and those were the kind of
films I've always aspired to make I've
rarely been out to make anything like
them but they're what I admire because
they they ask me questions and I suppose
contemporary ones
Kevin Hall is an overlooked filmmaker
he's a wonderful film he made a film
called Einstein's brain
it was just a wonderful brilliant film
and I suppose filmmaker from a human
point of view John Pitman made lovely
lovely films he died not long ago and I
admire those filmmakers because they
were they were interested in ideas they
were very honest a lot of filmmaking now
the people who hold the purse strings
don't allow the filmmakers to do what I
know they want to do I mean I worked
with young filmmakers and when I've been
in front of the camera and they really
want to make more challenging films
films that grapple with ideas and
they're not being allowed to and I find
that sounds I think it will change
because I think the broadcaster's are
dinosaurs and they're dying on their
feet I've been saying the 7 for 20 years
which is why I'm not on that Christmas
card list but it's true but I think what
is happening is people outside
broadcasting are beginning to fill that
gap and say you know what you're wrong
it's not just fantasy Islands or Big
Brother that people want to watch there
is an appetite but it'll be mix Hansel
et CET be more like the Renaissance
where you had people who wanted to be a
benefactor of an artist a painter or a
sculptor or a thinker and I think for
better or worse minute I don't know
whether it's a good thing or a bad thing
I think that will begin to happen for
motivates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you